la primera línea de frente aquí en el
este de ucrania en la región de heart
sigue moviéndose constantemente y lo que
estamos viendo sobre el terreno son
pueblos partidos a 8 km de aquí de este
punto donde nos encontramos en este
momento están las tropas rusas nosotros
no podemos cruzar porque somos prensas
tampoco pueden cruzar los militares
ucranianos pero la población si lo está
haciendo está cruzando del otro lado
para abastecerse de comida y también de
gasolina un bien que está escaseando
estamos en un momento en que la
contraofensiva ucraniana continúa los
combates están siendo particularmente
intensos en el donbass y también está el
sitio es un lugar estratégico porque se
encuentra a poca distancia de zuma una
ciudad tomada por los rusos